wow yeah so there's what did they base  that decision on like why have have they  why why has someone in a laboratory or  some sort of assumingly scientific field  decided that that is the age before like  giving an opinion on why and what I  think it used to be 28 and then when  because you think this it was 1967 when  the abortion act come came in and um  actually when it first came in it didn't  come in to to give you a a right you  know like it's different to America  where it was deemed a riot  um it was actually for extreme  situations and that's why what Laura  mentioned about you need to have two  doctors because there's actually to to  sign off whether they think you should  be able to have one and it's under  things like if you're if the um to  continue with the pregnancy is going to  impact your mental health